hey Eriksen I ever heard of a director
named Michael Bay
I have oh ha yeah he did not direct this
this is Dunkirk trailer number 2 or main
trailer
I'm Greg Alba hey what's your name Cara
Ericsson Tara Ericsson the lovely
talented beautiful funny
Tara Ericsson is here on the real
rejects again follow Tara Ericsson on
YouTube Instagram and Twitter
Tara Ericsson is her name I'm doing
hypnosis on you Tara Ericsson here at
Christopher Nolan ban yes the dark night
yes my mother only movie has ever done
sure was good too so as mementos Dark
Knight is but The Dark Knight is the
best movie I think he's done I think
this is the first true story he's ever
done yeah I think you might be right and
he produces he produced movies his wife
which I appreciate she produces yeah
yeah love is an important quality to
keep movies going more brothers no
monetization on this video what does
happens it could also mean the truth is
Austin
[Music]
she'll go on to the end we shall never
surrender : darling we have to go to
Dunkirk ready on the stern line we did
it
yeah well going into Mordor I'll be
useful say yes party
[Music]
discombobulated
[Music]
and they need and more everything's
closed
to activate the cylinders
visit when you quit
Don't Tell Gert
[Music]
your vision fayla to the bloody Navy
should be at home
[Music]
is no hiding from this Sun we have a job
to do
[Music]
apart from landing ground
Oh
[Music]
oh yeah
[Music]
fire oh that's like my worst fear get
caught in between two boats and being
squished to death and wrong sliders is
what that was an intense trailer Alex so
good that trailer really reminded me of
just how intense Nolan's films can
actually be bit like they don't look
cool and have great acting and
storytelling
I always forget before I go to watch a
Nolan film how long the edge of my seat
we're going to feel what I'm liking this
Alec
suspenseful this is all going to feel I
like war movies in general I like it
when they're very tailored to a very
specific location you know yeah I agree
Dunkirk location that Dunkirk events
because it's not like exploring all the
World War 2 it's exploring this one
specific time very specific battles as
well I saw before it before Kong Skull
Island there was a lot of IMAX and they
showed you an entire sequence of Dunkirk
like ah that was like seven minutes long
well I had no idea that we're going to
show it it was that scene they see with
Tom Hardy trying to shoot down that
right they they shoot it with IMAX
cameras and usually when you go to like
an actual IMAX theater and takes up the
middle of the screen doesn't hook up the
entire screen holy it would like the
most crystal-clear quality so you're
going really in the moment be you do see
how it's a different kind of war action
scene usually when you see these like
plane fighting scenes are really cool
and stylized a lot of a lot of planes
are going down yeah that seemed really
captured how hard it cuz he's just going
to this little scope it's not like
technology's been advanced with a right
guard
so she's the rocket you know he's going
to little scope and he has to align it
with this one [ __ ] dot he's got here
and then he has to shoot and try and
make sure what if his bullets can take
down the plane right and it was super
suspenseful super intense while they're
trying to also get this guy's on a
gurney and they're trying to see people
are trying to carry them across well
like planes are coming in and watching
that sequence and seeing it here
trailer here just this is going to be a
super intense movie that I'm surprised
is actually pg-13 yeah me too I like
that you said that about the scene II
saw Tom Hardy because a lot of
Christopher Nolan's like his pickups you
know a subordinate normally like they do
a lot of quick cuts for and films and
stuff Chris won all know that like
slightly but it's way more nolan
stylized which i enjoy because you can
still follow it i forgive you the
directors our movie I've seen words like
it's too quick and you're like what the
f is going on and I hate that and I like
that and I I just think that it's going
to be one of those things where he just
takes his time you really know how to
tell a story but he also knows how to
like keep the pace of it or not like on
snoozefest it's good I'm not excited and
I love Tom Hardy are you kidding me
Isaac
is one of the under noted an actor
because he's phenomenal in my opinion
and like all of his stuff whether I
started filming together they're doing I
like how no one has his actors that he
loves to work with you know Killian
Murphy were Chilean or Cillian or I
don't give a damn how you state is also
about my belly and I yeah Murphy's in
the film and he looks really good Tom
are do is kicks ass it's one of the
things where the trailers have yet to
show me who the characters really are
but you could still feel there's going
to be an emotional intensity to know
yeah when you're backing it with a lot
of great actors like one Direction's
Harry Styles you know that that's where
most of my face yeah your job was I was
gonna die yeah he's gonna die he you're
gonna get all that every Styles
character is I mean that's he's gonna
drive that whole I guarantee you after
this One Direction sales are gonna go oh
man they're finally going to be a we're
gonna stop being a little unknown band
and they're going to become popular
they might just become a little known
Oscar truth it might well be look at all
the war sound they compose the music
support yeah forget about our pop
singles yeah we're moving into feature
film singles actually really quick going
on the actual point because mine was
nobody ever say what are your
show points what you were saying about
the quick cuts and stuff one thing that
no one does very well in his films is
that when there's a lot going on you
know because I like the dark knife all
right it'll cut the Joker cut the Batman
cause it got to Commissioner Gordon all
that's going around the same time
they're kind of different places where
they're at he knows how to do that
seamlessly where it's not just focused
or one character is he cuts around to
several in this school in his long
sequence which adds to the intensity and
that's something that he does very well
in that 7 minute clip that we saw yeah
and seeing here to the trailer is I
imagine will be sequences where you're
beyond the edge of your seat while
cutting around to your kenneth branagh
is here's where tom hardy is so yeah and
it's all playing out at one time for a
war movie break if he can do that in
just a movie that's not a war movie yeah
because in a war movie you kind of have
to do that because there's going to be
so much bullet slicing excluding yeah 19
explosions I can see don't be at the top
of his game and at the same time I mean
at first when I heard it was pg-13
I was a little letdown cuz I'm like it's
a war movie and it's PG 3 right right
but seeing the way how the action is
hearing all yours no Tyler Tyler yes and
exactly I swear it is valid yeah we've
got time to advise how many of us with
civil leadership we need takers that's
what we have time for the one we need to
keep the language clean if we're going
to survive around all you need to say is
your date time sailors we need to make
an end of story
we don't need [ __ ] Navy we just need
me baby okay
I do think it because that first opening
scene in The Dark Knight where where
they're robbing it they come in off that
truck I mean that's a lot to follow when
they go in and they wreck all those
people
I am engulfed within the first 10
seconds I literally was sitting in the
movie there guy couldn't get enough to
just be like immediately I was in love
with the movie yeah in love and still em
and like obsessed with it and I think
because this movie has more of a depth
to it and we're talking about like a you
know were long yeah that he's he's going
to treat it with a lot of respect and I
think that will be pretty fairly
engulfed right off of that I hope so and
it's interesting because ever sent that
man beat
he hasn't done a movie that necessarily
takes place in realism right are you
ready yeah like obviously Batman movies
are hiding in a comic book world but a
realistic take of a comic book world in
you now then he did like prestige which
gets a little ridiculous and then his
inception and her seller since insomnia
this will be his first movie that's like
this has to be completely grounded in
realism yeah by the same time is there
spectacle yeah so it's going to be
interesting to see how he takes all the
skills and talent he learned of
spectacle yeah but putting it in pure
realism at the same time yeah could be
this could be one of his best-known
hopefully I'm on worldly world tear was
a spectacle yeah that's how people look
back on it Warren
yeah okay surprise Betty hello wow that
was fun I'm glad you're here to do this
trailer that I know you begged a you can
subscribe to reject channel reject Vil
reject Nation quick notification valve
we recently wants the patreon exclusive
video segments on there and launching
merch next week on their rattle you can
check it and ten Henrickson is on
YouTube Twitter and Instagram she also
has a Facebook page and she is really
funny she is really sweet she helps out
children in Africa
on a daily basis constantly making trips
back and forth don't know how she does
it I don't even think it's possible
goats cry all night Mike animation oh
there is do it welcome to my idiot army
and go subscribe to watch my videos you
know like comment dislike it you know
whatever whatever you feel right no
pressure could also follow me on Twitter
a feature erikson Instagram asked her
Erickson I post daily I do stories
Gregory watches my story i watch i watch
sounds look at most of your pictures and
stories all the time and I have a
Facebook page actor Tara Erickson
because I do all their stuff too I don't
get away you don't like my pictures I do
I like I do double heart on them
no you don't I do because I don't know
the other one the other day he was with
my friend Amy castle and they're doing
three do one day that will you deserve
amy was in there you know natural what
about the shirtless photo I second he
didn't do any of that
mm-hmm you know he's had no challenge
proton from you oh right right all right
I declined now now that whole exchange I
blacked out
the second the shirtless photo came in I
went I was I was gone for about 48 hours
and someone came to my house they were
like whoa where has he been trying to
get ahold you nice s Gregory Alva sent
me this picture and then they they
blacked out and then they had to stay at
my place two days I take care of them
and then just kept it I mean it was like
two weeks so that's why I blocked it out
so I forgot you know I'm really working
on my weight loss Birmingham right and
this has is gonna cause me to binge yeah
I'm gonna go well here's here's the
thing I sent him one back I said you
know what I should be fair I'll send him
one too and then I mean not just 48
hours I didn't hear from him for about
30 days well yeah I was vomiting a lot
it's rough when you look at that's why I
said I don't have bikini pictures on my
Instagram because people just start
projectile vomiting all over it's like
you think she'd look great right but no
oh boy right yeah surprise right which
is cool that people are surprised they
think I look great but I guess it's more
it's the worse in the long run actually
at the end of it when they just start
they vomit and they ruin things then we
vomit ruins things you know when your
computer's gone the cameras gone it's
just this is Greg and Tara's tips on how
to flirt right here game changers game
changers helping you guys and girls at